ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer
mitten der hölle von mario pohl wir
blicken mit dem reinen das als auf
stahlwerk etwas wärme in das gesicht
dieses soldaten dieser dunklen höhle aus
kilometer langen katakomben kaum wasser
nichts zu essen verwundete überall kein
ausweg nach da draußen wochen lang
dorthin wo die sonne scheint
eingekesselt in der hölle jetzt die
wende mehr als 260 soldaten wurden aus
dem stahlwerk geholt endlich unter ihnen
rund 50 schwerverletzte
die wurden in bussen abtransportiert
schauen wir in die gesichter blicken wir
ihnen die augen dieser menschen die
jetzt raus sind aus dieser hölle diese
augen haben dinge gesehen die niemand
sehen sollte verletzte 600 verletzte
teilweise fehlenden arme oder beine
viele wurden nur notdürftig versorgt wie
dieser soldaten diese hölle jetzt
verlassen kann in bussen werden sie weg
gebracht doch es geht nicht in die
freiheit es geht ihnen die ungewissheit
denn diese busse bringen sie in russisch
besetzte gebiete in der ukraine sie
sollen später in einem
gefangenenaustausch zurückkehren
insgesamt 1000 soldaten verschanzten
sich ja in den dunklen katakomben des
stahlwerks während putin seine bomben
immer wieder herab regnen ließ jetzt
sind sie raus aus der hölle von mario
pohl und auch die verbliebenen soldaten
sollen aus dem stahlwerk geholt werden
es wird ihnen passiert und wie so vieles
in diesem krieg denn in diesen krieg
gibt es keine sicheren pläne das sagt
der kommandant der soldaten im stahlwerk
dennis prokopenko
alles in frage gestellt werden jede
getroffene entscheidung jeder plan jede
maßnahme kritisches denken hatte meinem
kopf immer zweiter geweckt zweifel an
der richtigkeit der entscheidung es ist
nie über die vernunft hinaus gegangen
und hat mich nicht daran gehindert auf
meinem eigenen standpunkt zu beharren es
ist immer ein risiko einheiten zu
bewegung im krieg gibt es keine sicheren
pläne und operation man geht immer ein
risiko ein die hauptsache ist dass man
sich alle risiken bewusst ist dass es
einen plan b gibt dass man sich voll und
ganz auf diesen plan einlässt der es
ermöglichen muss die zugewiesenen
aufgaben zu erfüllen und das leben und
die gesundheit der soldaten zu schützen
vielleicht ist der krieg aus diesem
grund eine kunst aber keine wissenschaft
wenn sie eine aufgabe erfüllen und dabei
die größtmögliche anzahl von personen
ist das die höchste stufe der trommler
führung dies gilt umso mehr wenn ihre
entscheidung von der obersten
militärischen führung gebilligt wird
immerhin die soldaten aus dem stahlwerk
sie sind am leben sie waren sie sicher
dass sie im eingekesselten stahlwerk nun
doch auf ihren tod warten und auch
präsident wurde mir seelands gehen
betonte in seiner täglichen
videoansprache die ukraine brauche ihre
helden aus mario pohl und zwar lebend
was die lage mario pohl betrifft dank
der maßnahmen des ukrainischen militärs
der ukrainischen streitkräfte des
geheimdienstes der verhandlungsgruppe
des internationalen komitees vom roten
kreuz und der uno hoffen wir dass wir
das leben unserer jungs retten können es
gibt auch schwer verletzte unter ihnen
sie werden versorgt ich möchte betonen
dass die ukraine ukrainische heldenleben
braucht das ist unser prinzip ich denke
dass jeder vernünftige mensch diese
worte verstehen wird die operation zur
rettung der verteidiger von mario pohl
wurde von unsere militärischen
geheimdienst eingeleitet die arbeit geht
weiter
die männer nach hause zu bringen diese
arbeit erfordert feingefühl und zeigt
und wir gehen direkt in die ukraine nach
hf zu unserem kollegen bieren stritzel
guten morgen werden jetzt diese wende
alle kämpfer 1000 waren es waren sicher
man warte dort in diesem stall weg nur
auf den sicheren tod jetzt konnten doch
ein paar von ihnen gerettet werden und
die evakuierung soll ja auch weitergehen
wie ungewiss ist ihre zukunft und wie
kam es überhaupt zu dieser wende
naja dieser gefangenenaustausch scheint
mir aufgrund der schweren verletzungen
und aufgrund der versorgungslage war
tatsächlich der letzte ausweg gewesen zu
sein denn die zum einen die verteidiger
dort in einem stahlwerk für sich gesehen
haben und zum anderen aber
wahrscheinlich die militärische führung
beziehungsweise auch die politische
führung des landes die sich
offensichtlich so sicher ist dass sie
genügend der gegenseite dem den
russischen streitkräften beziehungsweise
werden wir putin anbieten kann in form
von einem gefangenenaustausch dass sie
sicher sein können dass diese eigenen
soldaten eben ja tatsächlich überleben
beziehungsweise überhaupt gepflegt
werden ich habe da ein wenig zweifel
wenn ich wenn ich sehe die rhetorik die
vorher in russland in der russischen
propaganda über die über die verteidiger
von mario pohl seit monaten jahren im
prinzip ja schon die schon sich
ausgebreitet hat und wenn uns zum
zweiten wenn man das vorgehen dieser
evakuierung vergleich mit dem was was
wir in anderen ländern gesehen haben
wenn ich sehe dass zum beispiel das
internationale rote kreuz daran
beteiligt ist die das internationale
rote kreuz hat sich an der ethnischen
säuberung in aleppo beteiligt hat dort
auch kämpfer evakuiert die eine zusage
bekommen haben zu freiem geleit und
einige von diesen sind dann von denen
hat man nie wieder was gehört
was bedeutet das für mario pohl diese ja
auch strategisch so wichtige statt der
zunächst gleich an kriegsbeginn
eingekesselt wurde und jetzt die letzten
kämpfer die ausgeharrt haben obwohl klar
war dieser widerstand der wird
vermutlich zu keinem erfolg führen was
bedeutet das für die stadt ist jetzt
gefallen sie endgültig jetzt in
russischer hand
also noch ist diese evakuierungsaktion
er noch nicht komplett abgeschlossen und
wenn sie dann tatsächlich irgendwann
abgeschlossen sein sollte dann ist
natürlich ja dann ist diese stadt
komplett unter russische kontrolle
allerdings die diese stadt hat mehr als
80 tage ausgeharrt die partei die ja mit
mehr als 80 tage ausgeharrt haben wird
immense ressourcen invensor streitkräfte
der russischen der russischen armee
gebunden die ja nicht eingesetzt werden
konnten einen anderen kriegsschauplätzen
was jetzt übrig bleibt ist dann den
weiten teilen zerstört ist mario pohl
dass das wieder aufgebaut werden kann in
naher zukunft auch angesichts der
wirtschaftlichen schwäche russlands dass
das ist nicht absehbar du bist in
kharkiv auch diese stadt strategisch
wichtig auch diese stadt seit beginn des
krieges unter massiven beschuss auch
wenn es jetzt gelungen ist dort die
russische armee zurückzudrängen sogar
bis an die russische grenze die er nur
einige kilometer entfernt liegt
beschreiben uns einmal die situation
heute in diesen tagen der stadtrat
kharkiv also in symbol für putins krieg
gegen die ukraine doch jetzt eine wende
nach der erfolgreichen gegenoffensive
der ukrainischen armee ist die stadt
wieder unter kontrolle
normalität stadt kriegsverbrechen die
metro soll wieder fahren und die
menschen sollen den schützenden
untergrund wieder verlassen rückblick
wochen lang steht die ukrainische stadt
unter beschuss unaufhörlich schlagen
putins bomben und raketen ein töten
zivilisten zerstören wohnhäuser der
einzige schutz für die menschen die
metro hier suchen sie seit monaten
schutz vor putins bomben die metro wird
zum lebensmittelpunkt der menschen hier
verbringen sie ihren tag hier essen und
schlafen sie hier feiern sie kinder
geburtstage und hochzeiten
jetzt also sollen die zivilisten den
schutz im untergrund verlassen und haben
angst angst vor einem erneuten angriff
der russischen armee sowie diese familie
vater und mutter tatjana und tochter in
sie ziehen jetzt zurück in ihre wohnung
danke ich habe gemischte gefühle
es ist immer gut heim zu kommen aber ein
bisschen beängstigend wegen den
beschüssen und den raketen obwohl es
unwahrscheinlich ist getroffen zu werden
wir frauen sind einfach ängstlich ich
muss heim weil die arbeiter gesagt haben
dass die metro bald wieder fährt deshalb
müssen wir jetzt heim auch nastia
fürchtet sich davor die schützende metro
wieder verlassen zu müssen
ich habe große angst weil ich allein
wirklich allein bin ich habe nur meine
freundin natascha sie hilft mir mit
allem deshalb hoffe ich dass alles gut
wird
die menschen in rage sie haben angst
aber auch die hoffnung dass sie nie
wieder zurück müssen in die metro vom
frage
wie ein schlüssel weiterhin bei uns aus
aktiv zugeschaltet die menschen die dort
jetzt ein stück normalität zurück
gewinnen können und gleichzeitig vor der
herausforderung stehen mit der angst und
den herausforderungen dieses kriegs
alltags umzugehen wie meistern sie das
also die menschen die wir dort gesehen
haben die in der metro seit fast drei
monaten gelebt haben die hatten ihn
gestern als der plötzliche als die
plötzliche ansage kam dass sie hier ihre
temporäre zuflucht für verlassen müssen
große angst viele von denen haben
tatsächlich dann die metro innerhalb
dieser letzten jahr 200 monate nicht
verlassen und fürchten sich natürlich
immer noch auch wenn sie sich freuen auf
ihre rückkehr in ihre wohnungen sofern
sie welche haben fürchten sich natürlich
immer noch davor dass hier der krieg
zurück wagen könnte man hört hier immer
noch aus der ferne artilleriefeuer
raketeneinschläge das ist natürlich die
kämpfe den umliegenden ortschaften dass
es nichts was jetzt direkt die stadt
weiter betrifft diejenigen die stadt
selber wird glaube ich seit anderthalb
wochen nicht mehr nicht mehr recht nicht
mehr direkt beschossen allerdings ist
wie gesagt der kriegsalltag nur steht
nur unmittelbar vor den toren der stadt
vor in einigen vororten beziehungsweise
dörfern und insofern ist diese dieser
sorge die viele der bewohner aus der
metro hatten durchaus berechtigt weil
das ist natürlich etwas eine situation
wenn nur 20 30 kilometer weiter entfernt
artilleriegefechte stattfinden kann man
sich vorstellen möchten viele leute
nicht bekannten haben da kann kein
besonders hohes sicherheitsgefühl sagt
bian stritzel über die aktuelle
situation in prag im osten der ukraine
vielen herzlichen dank dir für diese
information